[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
connecticut prosecutors refused to retry
michael skakel
michael really was convicted because of
a media
lynch mob his relative robert f kennedy
jr discusses the case
and a dissenting judge's criticism of
his own family
a hearing for actor danny masterson
accused of multiple rapes
and an nba player accused of striking
his girlfriend
plus we break down new body camera video
in the police shooting of a boyfriend
and girlfriend
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with ryan
buckmeyer and terry austin connecticut
prosecutors have announced they will not
retry michael skakel the so-called
kennedy cousin convicted by a jury
of murdering 15-year-old martha moxley
in 1975.
in 2018 the connecticut supreme court
overturned skagel's
2002 conviction saying skakel's defense
attorney did not properly present
alibi testimony at trial now prosecutors
say they won't try the case a second
time because too much time has passed
and some witnesses are dead robert f
kennedy jr is michael skakel's cousin i
spoke with him a short time ago about
the case
he says prosecutors secured the original
conviction through the help of a
doctored video
which took the defendant's words out of
context he also says skakel did not
benefit from his connections to the
kennedys to the contrary
he says skakel was burdened perhaps even
targeted
because of his family prosecutors have
said
that part of the reason they're not
trying this case again is because 17
of their 51 potential witnesses have
died
and they don't believe they can try the
case beyond a reasonable doubt
is that a sufficient explanation in your
opinion as to why this case shouldn't go
forward
no and it's not a credible explanation
because
um they were fighting
18 months ago to go to the supreme court
for the right to try it again
or for the right to have michael
continue to be convicted so they've been
fighting to
drive his case they've refused for six
years since he was released
to uh to make an announcement about
whether or not they were going to drop
the case they tried this case before by
the way with dead witnesses
so basically they have no evidence left
to
to convict michael skakel and he has a
very very convincing third-party
culpability defense where he can point
to somebody else and say
here are the guys who actually did the
murder and we have a full confession
from one of them
so this is why you said in the new york
times the other day that you would have
quote made a mockery of prosecutors if
they
tried this case again it sounds like
you're making an opening statement here
well no there's a lot of believe me if i
was making the opening to say man it
would go on for hours
but those are just some of the pieces of
evidence that
you know i think the new
prosecutor mr angelo
actually took a fresh look at this case
and said why do i want to tar my career
and tar my reputation by bringing a case
against an innocent man
tell me about your relationship with
michael skakel why is
this case involving him so important to
you
well it was only important to me because
i knew he was innocent
actually at the time that i wrote my
article for the atlantic monthly
and the time i wrote my book my
relationship with mike was very rocky
at that time and michael was angry and
wasn't talking to me so
i had no reason i mean you know it
wasn't
listen i love michael skakel and he
played a really key part in my life
during my early sobriety he got sober a
year before i did he's incredibly
courageous
and um incredibly uh
just a good person and very devout
and he um and
extraordinarily honest but he also you
know he had a hard life
he was virtually tortured for two years
at
illinois which was this kind of
reformatory where he was sent
as a kid and he's mistrustful of people
and unfortunately i fell into that net
during
a certain time of you know after his
conviction he
he blamed everybody including members of
my family and i was
um and you know so i did not
have a good relationship with him at
that time
but i'd known him and i've known him
intimately for many years and i knew
that he did not commit this crime
i want to read a line from the dissent
from the connecticut supreme court
opinion which ultimately flipped the
conviction it complained that
other people in connecticut who don't
have your family's financial resources
social standing even ethnicity and
connections to a political dynasty
wouldn't have gotten the same decision
that michael skakel got from the
majority of the court
in flipping the conviction what's your
response to that criticism of your
family
from the dissent on the connecticut
supreme court
i don't think michael skakel i mean i
know for a fact
michael skakel would have never been
convicted if he
if they could not have made a a
connection to it much to the kennedy
family and of course michael
is like igloo who was you know
repeatedly and
habitually called kennedy cousin in the
um in the press actually has no
kennedy blood in him michael really was
convicted because of a
media lynch mob
you know listen black kids
and poor people get convicted all the
time
in this country for crimes they didn't
commit and that
is you know that is a documented truth
we know that a lot because of the
innocence project
prosecutors have an easy job convicting
people
even innocent people and michael
you know if they have a reason to do it
they can do it and
michael was you know uh turned into kind
of a villain
by the press and of course because he's
uh under indictment he can't speak in
his own defense
and i'm sorry but it's clear that mike
would have never been
indicted he would have never been
convicted if
it had not been for his connection to my
family but
you know i'm not disagreeing with the
judge that it's easier to be rich in
this country
and it's better to be rich normally if
you're in the justice system than it is
to be poor
robert f kennedy jr appreciate your time
here on the law and crime network
thanks for having me and still ahead
here on law and crime daily our
assessment of the michael scale case
plus legal issues surrounding actress
lori lachlan actor johnny depp
and nba player terence davis and later
on in our broadcast a new series of
videos shows what happened and what did
not happen
when police opened fire on a boyfriend
and girlfriend killing
one of them those another reports when
law on crime daily continues
hey brian and terry i want to bring you
into this discussion about the michael
scale case we know prosecutors aren't
moving forward with
a second trial after the supreme court
flipped the conviction terry let's talk
about the facts of the case though we
had a conviction
michael skakel was convicted of this
crime by a jury
and some of the evidence was a golf club
that was found near the victim's body
and the exact type and size and make of
golf's club
was missing from the defendant's home
you know what
aaron that's a lot of circumstantial
evidence and the fact that he lied about
his alibi the fact there are no
other suspects and the fact that they
were all
out together that evening i really think
that it all points to him
and you know obviously he had a great
defense he had great attorneys it helped
him to get the
conviction overturned but you know at
this point i
kind of understand why the family
doesn't want to go through this again
especially since the prosecution has
lost 17 of the
51 witnesses and they have no additional
evidence
and brian one of the complaints that
robert f kennedy jr made
is look the whole reason that my
relative was targeted is because mark
furman
of o.j simpson fame or infamy we should
say
decided to dig into the case and point
the finger at him people don't really
want mark furman running around pointing
the finger at them
yeah but mark furman can put a finger at
me he can point a finger at you can
point a finger at terry the difference
is there's going to be no evidence to
support a murder at least for me i'm not
sure about you two
but not against me either sure point the
finger but if the
prosecution can find the evidence to
drive that case then they're allowed to
continue
so exactly and in here what we had is
the court ultimately said that the
defense work and the first trial didn't
dig into the alibis
enough so it was a scathing opinion
pointed at the trial council
in the original case it's a case we
could talk about for hours but we've got
to move on
to our next report now a judge has
allowed one of the stars of that 70s
show to push back
his arraignment on sex crimes charges
danny masterson is accused of forcibly
raping three women
at his home in separate incidents
between 2001 and 2003.
masterson had the right to be arraigned
today but the defense
and the prosecution agreed to reset the
date for that arraignment to january 6.
part of the reason is because the state
hasn't handed some key evidence over to
the defense for inspection
my understanding is that the people have
yet to produce all of the discovery
is that correct well there is a certain
portion of discovery that has already
been turned over but there's some
additional discovery that needs to be
provided yes
and mr vanessa you need that before the
preliminary is that correct yes we do
your honor
all right so you're preparing to enter a
time waiver on the arraignment yes
you're on what date are you
using with your permission your honor
the parties have agreed to january 6
2021. time waiver is taken for mr
masterson for the arraignment to january
6 20 21
0 90. thank you very much just one of
the high profile cases making headlines
long crimes brian buckmeyer of course
here with several other celebrity legal
matters to report including the case
involving actress lori laughlin brian
yeah erin so my generation newer is anne
becky but now lachlan is another inmate
at the federal prison in california
lachlan is going to be reporting to a
federal
prison named dublin correctional
institution on friday
where she's now serving her two-month
sentence for her role in the college
admission scandal
lockland and her fashion husband massimo
giannilli pleaded guilty to conspiracy
charges over the summer they admitted to
paying half a million dollars
to get their daughter into college gia
newly will start serving his five-month
sentence
on november 19th actor johnny depp lost
his libel case against a british tabloid
that called him quote a wife beater for
his alleged acts towards ex-wife amber
hurd
depp sued the son and admitted he had
drug and alcohol problems
but said he wasn't violent with his
ex-wife lawyers for the son argued
photos
recordings and depp's own text messages
showed he beat her
she also testified depth threatened to
kill her several times
the united kingdom's high court sided
with the tabloid and ruled the claims
proved to be substantially true
toronto raptors guard terence davis has
been arrested in manhattan for allegedly
assaulting his girlfriend
according to the nypd davis faces
assault and criminal mischief charges
for striking the woman grabbing her
phone and breaking its screen
the spokesperson for the toronto raptors
said they are aware of the reports and
are seeking more information
thanks a lot brian the 17 year old
accused of murdering two people during
protests in kenosha wisconsin
is back in that state to face charges a
judge in lake county illinois ordered
kyle rittenhouse to be extradited last
friday
he was taken to wisconsin that very
night rittenhouse faces six
charges including intentional homicide
in the deaths of two men during
unrest sparked by the police shooting of
jacob blake over the summer
rittenhouse's lawyer tweeted he strongly
disagreed with the judge's decision to
extradite resident house
john pierce said kyle will be set free
and cleared of all charges in his
opinion
rittenhouse faces life in prison if he
is convicted
we're going to take a closer look now at
body camera video of a police shooting
in waukegan illinois
marcellus cenet was shot and killed
after a brief chase
his girlfriend tafara williams was shot
and survived
das cam video shows an officer chasing
the two here's the scene from
several angles
mlk passing south
they're going west on helmholtz
they just 50.
i was right behind you you almost tried
to run me over
i'm good i don't know about the car man
are you okay
they almost ran me over
and when we come back the events which
led up to that police shooting plus
our analysis and later on a triple
murder trial involving a pro baseball
player
who authorities say was running out of
professional luck
did anger over a contract lead him to
[Music]
kill
back to the police shooting which left a
boyfriend dead and his girlfriend
injured in waukegan illinois
before the break we showed you how it
ended here now is how it started with an
officer trying to take the boyfriend
into custody
on a warrant
right
what's your first name what's your first
name or what
you're marcellus right yeah
you you're under arrest man why because
i said
hey come on show me the hands pal i
ain't playing with you because i know
you
marcelous you're under arrest
because you got a warrant i got
marcellus
record that's recording two marcellus
you're under arrest
okay so brian we've talked about a
shorter version of some of those clips
in a previous broadcast but does seeing
more of the video change any of your
thoughts on whether the officer was
ultimately justified in pulling the
trigger later on
somewhat because as you see in that last
bit and i was kind of like tilting my
head
when he says you almost ran me over it
almost appears like his understanding
the officers
of being almost run over is someone
driving past him and i take that to the
to the second part where he says he
almost ran him over
where the car is backing up i don't see
the car coming that close that he could
have been run over the second part also
is
why wasn't aid rendered quicker and
that's going to be a big major problem
for this officer if he's charged
so terry we have the voice of the
girlfriend several times in those
recordings two different scenes
two different uh scenarios do you think
she was accurately describing what she
was doing she said she was just
backing up well you know here's the
question what was the state of mind and
i think the police officer twice as we
saw in both of those videos
was saying you almost ran me over and i
don't think the car almost ran him
over so i think that they were just
trying to get away not trying to kill
the police officer
and when we come back here on law and
crime trailey the trial of a former
baseball pro
whose defense attorney admitted he used
a bat to kill three people
will an insanity defense work more
testimony is right after the break
let's head now to the trial of a former
professional baseball player who admits
he used a bat to beat
three people to death terry's here with
an update on that case
terry so ex-player brandon willie martin
faces three counts of first-degree
murder
for the deaths of his father his uncle
and a security system
installer prosecutors believe martin
lost his baseball contract
and killed out of anger the defense
admits the facts
but says martin suffers from mental
illness prosecutors called a 3d
reconstructionist
who explained the damage done to the
skulls of the victims
yeah the facial and cranial anatomy was
what i was concerned with
and so the photographs um that was
selected and sent to you
the ui you just zoned in on the head
area
yes they were cropped so um with mr
swanson
um uh just briefly explain i know you've
told us the process that you've done
from pre-processing and processing and
post-processing
um integrate that
into what you did with mr swanson yeah
so
some of the photographs um that are here
on the left side
um such as the license photo here
in this photo below it were used for
superimposition
so that was for overlaying of the
3d template skull to these photos to
match
the anatomy some of the photos were used
for
trauma on the cross
defense attorneys questioned who else
had access to this witness's research
there was one person that you spoke to
is that correct yes
and her name was leota noche
dowdy is that right correct
how many times did you speak to her i
don't recall maybe
half a dozen did you put your
conversations with her
anywhere in your notes i don't believe
so when was the last time you spoke to
her
i made almost a year ago probably
is she someone that works in this field
she is a phd student at the university
in this field
and well in the field of forensic
anthropology
so she's in a different field than you
right yes this morning you gave me a
phone number for her do you remember
that
yes would it surprise you know that that
number is disconnected
okay so terry one thing that strikes me
with this case is whenever you've got to
get somebody on the stand to reconstruct
the skulls of people who've been killed
with a baseball bat
you're talking gruesome injuries the
question is
does it actually matter when the defense
is admitting this is what happened the
question
really is the defendant's mental state
i think that is the question aaron but a
lot of times we see
prosecutors make a big case out of
something they don't have to because
they want to make sure
that they get this conviction so they're
showing
the skulls and they're having this
reconstructionist
talk about it in detail because that
does actually
affect what the juror is thinking about
and it makes them want to
convict even further so brian did the
defense score
any points with that cross-examination
about the number being disconnected and
everything
uh i'm not sure but i also don't think
this is the place for the defensive
score points i think at this point in
time you just got to sit tight
and wait for that penalty phase because
like he's already said he committed the
crime
the question is whether or not he's
gonna be able to save his life through
an insanity defense or some sort of
mitigation
yeah brian i mean is there is there a
chance here based on what we've seen
thus far in this case a chance to win
the trial
oh no no no mitigate mitigation i think
there's a great chance where you have
all the facts there there's all the
possibility of saying
there is something mentally wrong with
this person and he should avoid the
death penalty
and if the jury finds that then
ultimately that's the outcome a lot of
times the defense has to play the long
game
in cases like this thanks a lot for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we appreciate it
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america and there is much to
discuss
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming the
lawn crime network
is everywhere and we invite you inside
the jury box
this is lawn crime
[Music]
[Music]
you